well I mean I think that the first
general rule is is that facts don't
speak for themselves simply transmitting
or translating the facts of science is
not necessarily going to win over the
public or open up understanding among
different segments of the public
oftentimes you have to take a complex
uncertain issues such as climate change
and translate in a way that connects to
something that public already
understands or connects to something
they already value so a great example
would be eel Wilson wrote this terrific
book called the creation and in the book
he writes it as an open letter to a
Southern Southern Baptist minister and
he says I'm an atheist your Southern
Baptist we might disagree in terms of
where life came from but we both share
this common value in the creation and he
uses that presentation that message as a
way to kind of grow the audience for
science introduced a popular science
book about environmental conservation to
a religious audience who might not
otherwise read a book like that and in
the in the article for the scientist and
in the talks that we give you know one
of our central themes is that scientists
themselves and scientific institutions
need to take more of a scientific
approach to thinking about communication
if they're going to be successful in
reaching out to the broader audience
they first have to understand their
audience and they first have to
understand the media system that's going
to translate their message and carry the
message and that takes research that
takes the application of a lot of
research and social science but actually
going out and doing the research the
focus groups the surveys to figure out
the best way to frame your message in a
way that's consistent with the science
but resonates with that hard to reach
non-traditional public that you're
trying to communicate